[Musica]
vi chiedo di fare un esperimento con me
pensate a stamattina
a quando vi siete alzati o alzate per
andare al lavoro Facciamo finta che non
lo smart
Working ripensate alle vostre
azioni avete vi siete alzati o alzate
avete aperto l'armadio cercando di
capire come vestirvi scorrendo tra le
diverse opzioni che avevate a
disposizione poi vi siete
vestiti avete cercato le chiavi di di
casa e il cellulare o magari siete
andati diretti perché li tenete sempre
nello stesso
posto Poi avete aperto la porta siete
usciti e avete seguito una strada
familiare che fosse a piedi a a in
macchina o verso la stazione dei
treni Vi
chiedo è stato difficile riconoscere i
vestiti
nell'armadio avete avuto difficoltà
a capire che avevate visto il cellulare
Quando l'avete
trovato e quanto tempo ci avete messo a
individuare la maniglia sulla porta nel
tentativo di
aprire se vi sembrano domande banali
dalle risposte banali e perché
per la maggior parte di
noi queste azioni che ricadono in quello
che chiamiamo generalmente vedere il
mondo è qualcosa di scontato e
naturale in realtà se ci fermiamo a
ragionarci un attimo il percepire il
mondo esterno attraverso la vista È
qualcosa di
miracoloso in ogni momento noi bruciamo
un sacco di energia soltanto per
convertire gli stimoli luminosi che
arrivano ai nostri occhi aperti in
Segnali elettrici che viaggiano lungo il
nervo ottico arrivano al cervello che li
converte in posizioni bordi colori forme
e poi li mette assieme in immagini che
per noi hanno un senso e questo avviene
continuamente che guardiamo gli alberi
in un bosco un dipinto la nostra
famiglia o una pagina
internet una tale quantità di stimoli
luminosi Segnali elettrici sforzo
mentale che se dovessimo fare questa
cosa per tutti gli stimoli luminosi i
milioni di stimoli luminosi che ci
arrivano ogni secondo che siamo a occhi
aperti Ci andrebbe in fumo il
cervello non possiamo semplicement
vedere consciamente tutti questi
stimoli Ecco quindi che
l'evoluzione ha fatto in modo che questo
sistema di elaborazione visiva
selezione filtr asse e semplific asse
questi
stimoli Diciamo che il cervello compie
delle scelte che lo aiutano a fare
economia prende delle scorciatoie che
rendono queste elaborazione di tutti
questi stimoli meno
faticosa queste scelte però hanno delle
conseguenze Non proprio
positive ad
esempio dato che la nostra attenzione è
limitata noi tendenzialmente la
focalizziamo su degli stimoli che
risaltano rispetto al resto come il
pallino rosso che sicuramente avrà
attirato la vostra
attenzione sempre per lo stesso
motivo quando uno stimolo inaspettato
compare nel nostro campo
visivo noi tendiamo a ignorarlo se siamo
focalizzati su altro in quel momento se
la nostra attenzione è focalizzata su un
altro compito
perché ci è di intralcio quello stimolo
diventa
inutile camminate per la strada vedete
una persona in fondo che credete di
riconoscere Cominciate ad aguzzare la
vista chiedendo se è veramente lui e non
notate il cartello cemento fresco
davanti a voi e lasciate una bella
stampa davanti a stimoli che possono
essere letti in maniera ambigua il
cervello sopprime le
ambiguità sceglie un'interpretazione
sopprime
l'altra scommette su C è più probabile
che stia vedendo in questo insieme di
simboli se io leggo quello centrale in
orizzontale leggo una b se lo leggo in
verticale leggo un 13 è impossibile
leggere Entrambe le cose
contemporaneamente le nostre aspettative
i nostri desideri le nostre
Giocano un ruolo molto forte nel modo in
cui leggiamo queste
ambiguità se avete la fobia dei ragni
qualsiasi macchia su un muro che
somiglia vagamente a un piccolo animale
con tante zampe vi metterà subito in
allerta penserete subito ragno e non
macchia di sporco sul
muro il cervello tende a cercare schemi
e immagini fam Chiari in ciò che ha
davanti anche quando davanti ha solo un
insieme di segni e di simboli che in
realtà non significano nulla di per sé
pensate a quante volte Avete visto la
faccia di una persona nel nella facciata
di una
casa sempre per questa necessità di
ricerca di familiarità
tendiamo a forzare le nostre
interpretazioni di ciò che vediamo sulla
base delle nostre esperienze passate di
ciò che abbiamo già visto per cercare
conferme se noi pensiamo a un uomo con
un cilindro un abito elegante un
papillon e un mazzo di carte ci viene
subito in mente un mago mettere realtà
magari è solo un amante del vintage che
colleziona mazzi di
carte tutto questo tutte queste trappole
della nostra percezione visiva sono una
consuenza del nostro esplorare il mondo
con i sensi semplicemente dato che la
vista è il nostro senso principale per
quanto riguarda gli stimoli visivi
diventano più
evidenti noi diciamo sempre che vediamo
con gli occhi ma in realtà vediamo con
il cervello
che sceglie cosa e dove vedere filtrando
gli stimoli che gli arrivano in base a
cosa gli serve
vedere e in base a cosa si aspetta di
vedere per cui c'è da meravigliarsi
che non sempre siamo consapevoli di
tutto ciò che abbiamo davanti agli occhi
e che
percepiamo c'è da meravigliarsi che non
sempre riusciamo a vedere le stesse cose
dalla prospettiva di qualcun altro c'è
da meravigliarsi di quanto
i meccanismi della nostra percezione
giochino sulla nostra visione del mondo
e quanto questo influenza le nostre
scelte Chi conosce molto bene questi
meccanismi sono i professionisti che
lavorano con la comunicazione
visiva chi crea infografiche mappe
visuali video animazioni visualizzazione
di dati e tutti quei prodotti che
servono a comunicare informazioni attra
le immagini sa bene che ogni scelta
nell'uso dei colori delle forme dei dei
simboli non è
casuale io stesso che lavoro disegnando
e visualizzando
informazioni sono consapevole che il
modo in cui rappresento quelle
informazioni
influenza le l'attenzione
l'interpretazione e anche le le azioni
di chi
guarda chi lavora in ambito di
comunicazione visuale sa che spesso deve
far sì che l'occhio di chi guarda si
concentri e vada a cadere proprio sulle
informazioni utili a raggiungere un
obiettivo e non su altre che questo
obiettivo sia cercare il percorso più
breve tra due stazioni della
metropolitana cogliere al volo i
concetti principali espressi da un
relatore in una
conferenza capire lo stato di
salute di molte specie sul nostro
pianeta minacciate o estinte o anche
solo seguire i passaggi per montare una
libreria
Ikea chi crea comunicazione visiva sa
che spesso deve lavorare per far sì che
la lettura di queste informazioni sia
univoca sia immediata e
abbia che comporti meno fatica possibile
per le per chi
osserva Sì anche se parliamo delle
istruzioni
dell'Ikea E se poi ci poniamo
l'obiettivo di cambiare
le le visioni l'immagine del mondo un
obiettivo ambizioso delle persone a cui
parliamo sappiamo che dobbiamo
allinearci a quei modelli dobbiamo
essere ben consapevoli di cosa
significano quelle forme quei colori
Quelle linee quei simboli per
loro solo dopo esserci allineati a
questi potremo aggiungere nuove
informazioni visualizzando le nuove
statistiche nuovi dati e sfidare quelle
immagini ovviamente Queste sono
strategie da
professionisti
ma non occorrono anni di
studi
per avere un po' più di chiarezza nel
mare di stimoli che ci investe ogni
giorno possiamo affidarci a una delle
armi più antiche a disposizione che
abbiamo in quanto esseri
umani il disegno a mano
libera qualcosa a disposizione di tutti
Tutti possiamo
disegnare e subito qui qualcuno Dirà Ah
io non so disegnare Al massimo faccio
l'omino con le stanghette mi sono
fermato alla casetta dei bambini
dell'asilo
Nocco Immaginavo non vi preoccupate
disegnare non è un'attività che richiede
talento artistico o per forza la
produzione di qualcosa di esteticamente
bello disegnare in primis pensare su
carta e espandere la nostra mente oltre
i limiti del cervello e questo ci può
far molto comodo se siamo impantanati in
un mare di informazioni da cui dobbiamo
districarci per compere delle scelte
difficili
come ve la faccio semplice vi ho parlato
di tre trappole della nostra percezione
attenzione
limitata difficoltà a esplorare le
ambiguità
e Forzare le interpretazioni sulla base
di cose che abbiamo già vissuto di
percezioni che abbiamo già
memorizzato cerchiamo di capire come il
disegno può aiutarci con una a una di
queste il disegno è prima di tutto
allenarsi ad osservare e capire davvero
cosa stiamo
guardando la prossima volta che siete
con qualcuno che amate Vi invito a fare
un esperimento cercate di di ritrarlo o
ritrarla Provate a disegnarne i
contorni se vi sentite a disagio provate
con una pianta in salotto o anche una
tazzina di caffè ancora più
semplice facendo queste esperimento
noterete come vi accorgerete di dettagli
che non avevate mai notato come dei
lineamenti attorno agli occhi della
persona che amate
o vi noterete quanto è verde e rigoglio
la pianta in salotto magari vi
accorgerete di una foglia secca dietro
che non avevate mai visto o di qualche
sbeccata sulla tazza di
caffè quando come abbiamo detto prima
siamo concentrati
su situazioni su problemi complessi
spesso la nostra attenzione può farci
perdere dei pezzi di realtà perché siamo
troppo focalizzati su quello o siamo
distratti da
altro quando ci troviamo a compiere
delle scelte difficili visualizzare lo
scenario e la situazione attuale può
aiutarci a capire a dettagliare chi sono
le persone coinvolte i luoghi i fatti i
problemi le opportunità e ad avere un
quadro più chiaro davanti della
situazione e magari renderci conto di
fattori chiave per la nostra scelta che
prima non avevamo notato o avevamo
trascurato il disegno può aiutarci a
esplorare appunto situazioni
ambigue che possono essere affrontate da
più
prospettive chi lavora con la
visualizzazione dei dati spesso Esplora
più modi di rappresentare le
informazioni che ha a disposizione
cercando quello più
efficace è un po' come se noi dovessimo
rifare la stanza da letto cercando di
capire quali mobili metterci come
disporli che colori e disegnando le
varie opzioni che abbiamo a
disposizione possiamo seguire lo stesso
ragionamento con scenari derivanti dalle
nostre scelte alternativi
rappresentandoli Magari Con prospettive
leggermente diverse enfatizzando più
determinati aspetti piuttosto che
altri poi
possiamo cercare di metterli a confronto
capire quali sono le differenze tra
questi scenari cosa ci piace e cosa ci
turba di ciascuno scenario ipotetico
Oppure possiamo capire cosa li accomuna
cosa li collega tra loro magari c'è un F
Rouge che unisce alcune di queste
possibili
scelte non volete farlo con scenari
figurati e disegnati va bene usare delle
mappe mentali anche dei diagrammi vi
aiuta a a esplorare i diversi aspetti
possibili di ciascuno scenario che avete
davanti e capire come ciascuna opzione
che avete di fronte si può sviluppare in
varie
direzioni che fare se anche a questo
punto abbiamo dubbi che ci stia
sfuggendo qualcosa o che non Abbiamo
esplorato tutte le prospettive o che la
nostra visione sia
distorta se io vi chiedo di pensare a un
cane
a ciascuno di voi verrà in mente
un'immagine mentale precisa derivante da
i rapporti che avete avuto con i cani
nella vostra vita dagli altri cani che
avete visto magari dal vostro cane Se ne
avete uno
Ecco se io disegno questo
cane tiro fuori dalla mia testa
quest'idea questa immagine la rendo
disponibile agli altri posso
confrontarla con l'immagine di cane che
ha avuto quell'altra persona e capire se
è simile a questa oppure se magari lui
ha immaginato qualcosa di più grande di
più piccolo di un'altra razza che abbia
che dorme eccetera
quando dobbiamo prendere delle scelte
difficili sottoporle disegnarle per
condividerle con qualcuno ci aiuta a
rendere più visibile la nostra idea
e sottoporla al vaglio dei punti di
vista e delle immagini mentali dei
pensieri di qualcun altro e magari
possiamo così renderci conto del lascito
del di tutto quello che si porta dietro
la nostra idea in termini di aspettative
di paure di desideri che magari ci
offuscano la mente rispetto a una scelta
che dobbiamo prendere
condividere può aiutarci a vedere a
farci vedere queste rotte alternative
qualcun altro ci può mostrare una strada
differente
questi erano solo tre modi in cui il
disegno può aiutarci in questo tipo di
attività quello che mi piacerebbe farvi
passare
è che appunto il disegno non è
un'attività che richiede essere degli
Artisti e non importa se non avete Sono
anni che non prendete in mano una matita
l'importante è che vi sentiate liberi di
esprimervi senza giudizio su quello che
producete
e che mettiate i vostri pensieri nero su
bianco quando è
necessario quando vi
sentirete dispersi in un mare di stimoli
e di
informazioni che magari vi offuscano la
vista
e vi impediscono di vedere le rotte che
avete a disposizione e di capire quali
sono quelle più adatte a voi vi
consiglio di affidare la vostra
Navigazione a questi
Grazie